[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at the legal trap and this is
actually my favorite trap just because i
see it more often than any other trap
out there so it starts out with pawn to
e4 which i like just because this is
kind of the opening that I usually start
with and black responds pawn to e5 very
common and why develops Knight to f3 and
black develops Knight to c6 and then
Weis going to transpose into the Italian
game with Bishop to c4 and as you can
probably tell everything that we've done
here so far is pretty common you
probably see it in almost all your games
and from here black has a few options he
can go into the gioco piano which is
Bishop to c5 you may see him develop his
knight to f6 the trap actually comes
about when he goes into the Philidor
defense which is pawn to d6 it's kind of
a passive defense but this is kind of
what the trap comes from from here we're
going to simply develop our Knight to c3
and a lot of players that they just like
to get their Bishop out and pinned down
a knight to a queen any time they can
are gonna come down as fast as they can
and pin your knight down to the Queen
from here we are simply going to
move pawn to h3 and most players the
best move for here is actually for
Bishop just to go ahead and capture on
Knight to f3 and we'll go over that in
just a minute but a lot of times black
likes to keep the pressure on the pin
and so he's actually just gonna move
this Bishop back to h5 and this is
actually a mistake is why it's actually
gonna go up in material now how much
material we'll see but from here we can
go ahead and lay the trap and that is
Knight takes e5 now as you can see this
looks really tempting for black as he
can come in and take the Queen this is
actually going to lose the game if black
does take the bait and capture on d1
then white can simply take on f7 check
the King he obviously cannot take this
bishop because we have our knight here
and he can't move to d7 because our
knight is here his only move is a 7 and
we can come with our Knight to d5 and
checkmate so obviously that is the trap
that's how they can fall into it let's
go ahead and take a look at a few
nuances that you'll want to take a look
at back in this example you saw we move
pawn to h3 and here's why if we already
move because a lot of people say why
can't I just move Knight to captures e5
well here's why if we take on e5 yes we
do have a trap that if they capture on
d1 then they will lose to checkmate
after we captured this light before on
f7 and then move
it's a d5 with our knight but black can
simply if he looks at the situation he
can actually just take on e5 and we've
traded our night for pawn we cannot
recapture this Bishop on g4 because his
knight is not protecting it now if you
look at this example after we move h3
and the bishop moves back then once we
take on e5 now if black takes on e5 with
his Knight instead of falling for the
trap now we can easily take the bishop
on h5 and the knight is no longer
protecting it so this small little h3
move is actually very important in this
trap because even if he moves back we're
still going to be up in material from
here obviously a lot of times you'll
just see Knight to c4 but from here
black excuse me why can just come to b5
with his Queen check and we are forking
the knight on c4 and we'll just take the
knight on c4 on our next turn and as you
can see we're up upon so even if black
does play the best move after he moves
his Bishop back and we take even if he
makes the best move here of Knight
captures a 5 we're still going to be up
in material and this is a big difference
then if we try right away to capture on
e5 now
I know a lot of people vast in the
videos well how can black a boy this
well there's two ways black can avoid
this one is what if you ever do come
across this trap as black one you can
just capture right away on f3 and not
even allow them to get the trap in or
two you can choose not to develop your
bishop here you can bring your knight to
f6 or at the very beginning just so you
don't have to go into it you can not
play a very passive move like pawn to d6
and you can develop your Bishop to c5 or
you can just develop your knight into
the game so it's a very very effective
trap because you'll see it a lot there's
no obscure moves or anything everything
is pretty straightforward and it's very
tempting for black to fall into the trap
and capture the Queen and even if they
don't you're still going to be up in
material so hope you guys enjoy this
video if you haven't already please
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next video thanks for watch